thanks to some stringent workouts 37
year old Kourtney Kardashian is fitter
than ever and she's showing off her body
in bikini after Bikini we're breaking
down all her best looks first in this
skimpy number we see just how thick
Kourtney really is toned and tan this
bottom is barely there and Kourtney's
got legs for days plus who needs a beach
when you've got basketball sexy and
athletics courts more covered up in this
swimsuit but that booty speaks for
itself on this one a keyhole cutout
makes the simple suit sexy the mom of
three gives us animal print amazingness
in this bikini and Kourtney kills in a
classic one-piece as well plus we know
she's not photoshopping her Instagram
post like some other celebs do because
she proves she looks this good with
video so how is Kourtney gotten so in
shape well she's really upped her
workout game over the past year get
ready to crush your anxiety this is what
gets us through our days Court is now
chronicling her almost daily exercise on
snapchat
and she has always been a proponent of
eating clean it's gonna be a divine